yo J ce que j'ai eu du Maseca
vous écoutez deux confiance Ice Cube
eazy-e
comme dr.  Dre ils veulent NWA tuons-les
en w-attendez quel argent mais pourquoi tu dois
être si impitoyable les factures ici
c'est un début
tu sais que les chars changent la situation le
prendriez-vous juste frapper ce premier être
dur meurtrir mes six [ __ ] de
haine  J'étais stupide, sois honnête avec toi, je
ne connais rien au hip hop mais je
sais que tu es spécial, vous êtes
censés être mes clients à
cause de ce à quoi ils ressemblent, vos
chansons lammer les yeux, les gangs et la drogue, notre
art est un reflet  de notre réalité
disant la vraie vérité et les gens perdent
la tête, mais ce ne sont pas les Crips et les
sangs, c'est une menace du gouvernement fédéral
, nous pouvons prendre le contrôle du
[ __ ] de whoa
maintenant vous passez de la vente de pierres dans une
maison de drogue au dîner dans  une maison blanche